today president biden held his first  formal press conference since taking  office in fact it just wrapped up a  little while ago  while he celebrated progress on  coronavirus vaccinations he was also  grilled by journalists about the crisis  at the southern border  the president says he inherited  immigration problems from the previous  administration  we're doing now is attempting to rebuild  rebuild the system that can accommodate  the what is happening today focusing on  the fundamental reasons why  people leave honduras guatemala and el  salvador in the first place  president president biden has put vice  president kamala harris at the head of  his administration's  border response meanwhile the u.s  government is adding more than 16  thousand emergency beds to house the  influx of children from  south of the border